last April Fool's Day thinkgeek came out
what they called the icade a little
miniature arcade gaming cabinet that you
can slide your ipad into a plate
thousands of retro arcade games and it's
been an April Fool's joke until now this
is the icade comes from ion audio which
work in partnership with pinky and Atari
to help bring actual retro arcade games
to your iPad you just slide in the iPad
through the top and through wireless
Bluetooth connectivity you can play
actual retro arcade games thanks to the
eight buttons and joystick on the
housing of the cabinet now the best
thing about the real icade is that
unlike its fake version which would have
cost you one hundred fifty dollars on
thinkgeek the actual icade is only going
to run you one hundred dollars iPad not
included